I can't bear to watch popular movies
about what it's in Churchill except to
now and I can't bear to read much about
him because it's so bad so I want you to
know I I think that this is this very
significant thing and I think that the
combination of these two men I don't
think anybody except mr. Ullman could
have done this so I just want to say
that I first I'll shut up now but I that
personally I think this is one of the
best things done in art in decades how
did I how did I get ready I just did it
was a year of Churchill everything
Churchill and to actually to the point
where Giselle would say I she said I go
to bed with Winston Churchill but I wake
up with Gary Oldman which which is
better than the other way round you know
I think she was she was she was a star
wall and watched every frame of footage
and I've read that read the books I read
and we would it so it was a it was
actually a real it was a real journey
and she would she would find these
things like my nickname for Giselle is
the finder of rare things and she would
find it's just it was she was she was a
marvelous companion on this on this
journey and the more I read about I read
your book you kindly sent me the more I
read about Churchill the more I watched
Churchill the more I listened to him the
more I just fill in I fell in love with
him and along the way in that part of
the process
you're very privileged in movie business
Gary Oldman isn't a play Winston
Churchill suddenly you get to go to the
war rooms after hours with no tourists
you get to go to Blenheim before hours
which is
before no tourists you get to go to the
war rooms and they open up the special
doors and they take away the velvet
ropes and Giselle and I got to be in
those rooms and Gary was able to be in
those rooms sit on Churchill's bed sit
in the chair yeah in the in the war room
there is the chair that the great man
occupied and on the on the arm of the
left arm of the chair are these sort of
divots and deep scratches which he had
made with his fingernails and on the
right hand arm of the chair are the
scratches which he made from the tapping
of his ring and for an actor you know
there's a there's a point what you can
read the books and you can you can study
the man but there is a point when you
have to sort of put that away and it
becomes less about an intellectual
exercise and more about a sensation or a
feeling that you have to have and it was
a real privilege and a wonderful
revelation to sit in the chair because
they're now in this piece of furniture
is behavior is the the anxiety and the
stress and all of that that he was under
and you can trace him with your hand and
actually touch noticing that so people
play Churchill this way Churchill was a
caricature of himself and he talks like
business and he growls all the time and
he walks really slow Churchill was
lightning quick mentally and physically
he was a fencer in college he played
polo until he's well into his 50s and so
to meet him was to meet a man who was
electric and Doug and I were sitting
back there watching the movie last night
and they zoomed in on the hand and it
was going like that and I said that
right he burned really hot all the time
see and you got that nobody else has
ever got that well it's in the newsreel
footage of this time of this very
specific window of time and a very
obviously a very defining moment in not
only in world history but in but in
Churchill's career going to this very
specific moment I noticed a man who was
energized on fire dynamic moving through
space with a fixity of purpose man on a
mission
Rubick naughty a sparkle in his eye and
the and this was not the sort of common
grumpy man shuffling around in his
monogrammed slippers dropping you know
sky rash on his wesker this this was a
man who was a leader leading us well you
said that one of the things we didn't
mention this earlier you didn't
mentioned but you said at some point
that one of the things that convinced
you to play Churchill was simply being
able to speak those lines and how often
do you get to speak once more unto the
breach dear friends in a major motion
picture you don't these days yeah I mean
when I was when I you know it wasn't all
I would have three days of working on
this role and then I would go wobbly and
I'd say to Doug Orr Giselle oh god what
if I let myself in for you know I can't
do it I won't be you know this is awful
I won't be any good and really it was it
was both it was Douglas and and Giselle
it separately but who said to me what's
the worst thing that could happen the
worst thing that could happen is you
could be really awful but in the process
you've got to stand in a room with 600
people and say
I have nothing to offer but blood toil
tears and sweat I get to stand in a room
and say we shall fight in France we
shall fight on the Seas and oceans so to
describe your workday with all that
makeup what was that like okay so we at
the at the beginning of at the very
beginning of the shoe sir my early days
my alarm clock would go off at like 1:30
1:45 2:15 we would be in the car and I
would get to the set at right 2:45
my first pick up on day one was at 1:45
so I had to be in the car at 1:45 I'd
get to the ser they would shave my head
which every day after after day 36 was
[Music]
that was that was now I'm not my morning
started they would shake my head and
then of course you then you have glue
and then and then the process will dice
and warm
no the glue isn't warm and Giselle was
there it make me some coffee and a
protein drink or something and then and
then it would be three hours 15 of the
makeup 45 and then another 45 minutes to
to get into the the suit clothes and
things but it it there was an added
advantage to this job that it was in a
bit that we didn't that we couldn't
foresee when we started
I was dressed and ready as Churchill
when the director arrived and the other
actors for rehearsal they never saw me
as Gary for three months they only met
me as Winston as interesting room number
one and you turn left to go into the
studio or you walk the corridor to go to
the through the other studio door
depending which set or side you were on
in the mornings and the background
artists and extras and various people
who were secretaries in the typing pool
the various soldiers that were there in
the war room they would line line the
corridor waiting to go on to the set and
I would emerge from the dressing room
and walk down the corridor and I would
emerge obviously made up completely as
Churchill and the reaction that was that
was there some of the women some of the
women's curtsied the men would come to
attention and stand back and salute and
it was a very strange it was because you
forget that you're wearing all of this
that's the thing so that a people are
reacting to you as Winston Churchill and
that was a it was a lot of fun it was it
was great to be p.m. for one oh I want
to add something you visited us on the
set when you see Gary's and Gary is a
stickler for detail as is our customer
Jacqueline Duran when you see Gary and
Winston suits those suits are made by
Winston's tailors when you see those
shoes they're made by Winston shoemakers
those are Winston's cigars
I think the watch was the not the actual
watch but it but the what type of watch
every detail the bowtie the Hat was made
by Winston's hat maker there was not a
thing that you were seeing in the
in of it that wasn't absolutely
researched and to the tiniest detail and
so kind of well what's that silk
underwear silk underwear that's right
how's that it's lovely
sure Churchill certainly liked it as he
said I could hear you silly get used to
you smoke all those cigars
[Music]
yeah I I went through I don't know if
I'm proud to say this are ashamed of it
a $30,000 worth of cigars yeah because
because again you know he could easily
get used to the best and they were about
fifty fifty bucks a pop and I got
through about 12 a day I think and I
subsequently got nicotine poisoning and
then I had a very very bad tummy and it
was it was so we had our Christmas break
and people went off to celebrate with
their families and decorate their trees
and by their presence and you know put
up the Holly and the mistletoe and I I
had a colonoscopy
now about mean actors I'll say this we
had dinner the night before penny and I
and two of our children went watch to
make this movie and you can't have got
to bed that night before 10:30 or 11:00
and then you're up at 1:30 or two
whatever it is and you go till five
o'clock four o'clock six o'clock right
so we watched you all day long that day
and you were cheerful and courteous to
everybody you saw and they saw you
including us all day long so you can see
why actors would be mean it's harder to
see why you're not we I mean I'm telling
you oh you know oh oh oh god I had to
work a long day you know and and that
that sound you can hear is the smallest
violin playing you know I figured if
you're going if you know if Winston
Churchill could take on and off Hitler
at 65 I can see it in a makeup chair for
three and a half hours you know life
could it could it could be a lot worse
so to me it and I'll say the college to
be a little part of this and have you
here in this worthy thing we are very
proud and we thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]